[Applaudissements]
nous sommes le 15 septembre 2016 et là
c'est le
drame je reçois maintenant celui qui a
été l'animateur star de la télévision
des années 2010 il était parti de rien
pour bâtir un empire télévisuel tout lui
réussissait jusqu'au jour où il a commis
l'erreur de sa carrière celle qui l'a
obligé à quitter définitivement l'écran
ça fait maintenant 10 ans que plus
personne ne l'a revu disant qu'on se
demande ce qu'il fait s'il est encore en
vie s'il a beaucoup grossi c'est notre
invité TTA où cyi Louna mesdames
messieurs
l'homme fait de Canal Plus une chaîne du
groupe
D8 Cyril
Anouna
alors Cyrille Valérie Isaac Anouna vous
êtes né le 23 septembre 1974 à Paris
dans une famille tunisienne arrivé en
France en
1969 contrairement à tout ce qu'on a
pensé des années vous n'êtes pas
d'origine
pakistanaise vous êtes d'origine
tunisienne vous avez bien caché votre
jeu Cyr faut dire votre père ananouna
est médecin votre mère est gérante d'une
boutique de vêtements enfance assez
agité vous passionnez pour le tennis
beaucoup plus que que pour vos études
Cyril je crois qu'on peut le dire après
le bac vous entamez des études pour
devenir expert comptable comme Laurent
rquier c'est vrai comme Laurent baffille
3 mois est-ce que est-ce que la
comptabilité rend marrant c'est très
marrant les bilans quand on fait bien
sûr avec là j'ai pris la voix de
Navaro c'est pas mal bon c'est sûr que
regardez Laurent il a toujours été drôle
même quand il compte Laurent baffi il va
très vite parce que c'est vrai qu'il
faut compter vite il faut vite et moi
pour rendre la monnaie maintenant dans
ma nouvelle activité c'est vrai que
maintenant ça me ça va bien bah oui bien
sûr alors parallèlement vous faites
plusieurs petits boulots comme employés
de banque VRP en en tissu hein aussi
mais à cette époque déjà là la
télévision vous fait rêver non Cyril
j'adorais ça moi ouais ah ouais vous
adoriez la télév j'adorais je me mtais
tout nu je sortais dans la rue ah voilà
les gens étaient contents mais on se
rappelle d'ailleurs votre première
apparition c'était dans le juste prix
comme candidat on
regarde venez là venez les deux là venez
venez tous les deux oui tous les deux
venez venez
[Applaudissements]
venez vous allez me faire l'AMB venez
aussi c'est Olivier comment il s'appelle
votre copain cy comment Cyr viens venez
Cyr je vous vous allez me faire la même
ambiance on va faire pe interview de
Carlos vous me faites la même ambiance
que celle que vous mettez dans le public
actuellement Carlos bonjour Vous venez
d'où Carlos je viens de Berl ber ber
[Applaudissements]
Berl ça me fait rire ça et vous gag quoi
cette semaine Carlos j'ai gagné un
[Applaudissements]
camescope stop et puis des jumelles ou
oui c'est bien ça le met en forme et pu
une selle de cheval
et voilà
alors oui c'est le début deouna à la
télévision extraordinaire ça c'était il
y a 20 kg
ça alors ensuite vous avez participé au
jeu que le meilleur gagne comme candidat
Nagi vous a d'ailleurs dit à l'époque
que vous alliez faire une une carrière
hein c'est extraordinaire parce que
maintenant il regretteent un peu
finalement non il regrette pas c'est
vrai que maintenant je le vois souvent
on va parler de ma nouvelle activité
c'est vrai que c'est une personne qui
vient souvent me voir cont alors vous
apparaissez alors dans la Grosse
émission vous êtes le stagiaire à
l'époque qu'on envoie à poil chercher
des trucs au super marché franc prix en
2003 vous remplacez Michel lun dans le
Morning Live d' M6 et vous restez pas
très longtemps sur M6 hein 3 mois payez
pas
assez ouis là commence les années
galères he à cette époque vous vivez
encore chez vos parents vous allez
rester chez vos parents jusqu'à l'âge de
30 ans Cyril 31 ans ouais quand je suis
parti ma mère elle a fermé la maison
et là vous rencontrez votre femme Émilie
à une époque vous n'avez pas d'argent
vous nêtes pas connu franchement c'est
faut la garder
ensuite vous présentez plusieurs
émissions un peu un peu sur toutes les
chaînes mais rien ne marche et en 2010
Cyril vous partez sur France 4 animé une
émission intitulée Touche pas à mon
poste et là ça cartonne ça cartonne sur
France 4 on était devantidia devant
France on était les rois du monde les
rois du
câ et en mai 2012 lors du mercato vous
signez sur D8 oua au début je croyais
que c'était une bataille
navale et là c'est un triomp en quelques
mois Touche pas à mon poste alias TPMP
devient l'émission phare de la chaîne
vous devenez culte vos chroniqueurs
deviennent des stars les audiences
s'envolent vous êtes à votre top à ce
momentl c'est le top vraiment vraiment
le top et vous êtes star le top le top
le top frérot le top le top la plupart
de vos émissions toutes les émissions de
D8 c'est vous qui les faitoyz les
étoiles frér on dit qu'à cette époque il
vous arrivit d'enregistrer deux
émissions différentes en même temps sur
deux axes caméras bien sûr il y a des
émissions je faisais même les
chroniqueurs et public ouis voilà c'est
extraordinaire voilà et à cette époque
c'est vrai que si on enlève Cyril Anouna
de de D8 reste plus que la pub même pas
même pas il m' il m'avit mis dans les
pubs également voilà on vous a même
demandé de participer à des épisodes de
Navaro exactement que la chaîne diffusé
hein je pens ça que je le doublé un
moment quand tu c'est ça fait même vou
mettre sur barnbist un anglais ça
passait pas alors justement touche pas
mon poste atteint les 20 % de part de
marché contraignant le Grand Journal à
s'appeler le moyen journal c'est là que
c'est arrivé non ça c'était déjà en
alors vous décidez de parler d'autres
choses que de télé avec touche pas à mon
ballon pour parler de foot touche pas à
mon slip c'est génial pour parler de
sexualité touche pas à mon pognon pour
parler d'argent touche pas à m'en
décolteré ça c'est une émission sur le
cancer du sein ou une émission je me
rappelle j'avais remis Naba ah ouais
j'avais mis des des couvert en plastique
i très
attention tout va bien pour vous tout
marche très bien nous sommes le 15
septembre 2016 et là c'est le
[Musique]
drame le DRAM vous décidez de lancer une
nouvelle émission intitulée touche pas à
mon
politique une émission censé redonner
aux gens l'envie de s'intéresser à la
politique Cyrille et c'est là que vous
invitez un soir Thierry
solaire ça se passe pas bien on
regarde bonsoir m petites beauté et
comme vous le savez j'ai décidé de
lancer une nouvelle émission nous sommes
à quelques semaines de l'élection
présidentielle bien sûr et j'ai décidé
de lancer cette nouvelle émission touche
pas à Monot
poli merci et pour cette première
émission je reçois Thierry solaire
applaudissement solaire donc député de
haute scène bien sûr vous pouvez réagir
à tout ce qu'il va dire ce soir parce
qu'il va parler à la France il va parler
au français vous pouvez réagir dès
maintenant sur bouou et sur tour on va
parler de tout ce soir Thierry bien sûr
on va parler chômage on va parler
économie on va parler bien sûr Affaires
étrangères on va parler de tout ce
quiattendent les Français on va parler
des problèmes des Français mais Thierry
la première question que j'ai envie de
vous poser ce soir est-ce que suc s'est
trompé vous aime beaucoup moi je suis
venu sur ce plateau pour parler de
politique moi je suis député de la
République pardon mais je crois que
voilà on s'est pas bien compris moi j'ai
rien à faire dans une
émission un coup ça
va c'est vra
quo à la représentation nationale les
gens croient en des choses il y a des
députés qui représentent les Français et
c'est pas ma personne moi on s'est
croisé régulièrement moi j'ai aucun
problème avec vous mais vous m'avez
expliqué qu'on vous une émission
politique voilà moi je suis pas venu
pour répondre à ces questions alors
est-ce que tu
[Applaudissements]
Tromp belle mentalité
voil
voilà
immense scandale alors que Michel rard
m'avait répondu avec amusement à cette
question qui faisait en fait référence à
à Bill Clinton là tout le monde vous
vous tombe dessus et tout le monde vous
dit comment peut-on poser une telle
question à un ministre c'est comme si
vous je vous posais est-ce que sublé
s'est
trompé ben
non ça a été très dur quand même à ce
moment-là je crois cy je crois que vous
l'avez vraiment vous avez morflé quoi je
crois qu'on peut le dire certains
sympathisants tentent de lancer le le
mouvement touche pas à mon tunisien ça
pas pris ça pas pris vous disparaissez
oui du jour au lendemain on ne voit plus
Cyril nanouna les premiers temps vous
faites comment pour affronter les
questions de ceux qui vous disaient bah
alors qu'est-ce que tu deviens je vi
vote je vivote j'ess j'ai essayé de
revenir j'ai contacté Laurent Ruet pour
qu'il me prenne dans les grosses têtes
ouais il m'a dit non tu n'as pas les
compétences m'a dit retourne sur repa en
face ensuite j'ai contacté plein d'amis
j'ai contacté Arthur ouais pour les
enfants de la télé m' dit non tu as pas
d'enfant tu aimes pas la télé tu viens
pas c'est ça c'est qu'à ce momentl vous
découvrez en fait que que les gens que
vous avez aimé vous avez invité tout ça
plus personne j'appel Nagi ouais et
alors j'ai j'aimerais prendre ta place
il m'a dit tout le monde veut
prendrece que vousisz
pendant toutes ces années cy au départ
j'ai je me suis dit quelles sont mes
forces aujourd'hui ouais moi c'est vrai
que j'ai une force déjà ma force moi
c'était mon physique ouais ça dû être
extrêmement difficile non ah oui non non
franchement très difficile heureusement
qu'it ma femme elle m'a retrouvé comme
elle m'avait connu c'est vrai que
pendant un temps vous êtes parti vous
vous cacher au Pakistan je vous AES dit
là-bas personne va me reconnaître en
fait personne m'a
reconnu alors vous tentez époque de de
vous reconstruire et là c'est
extraordinaire avec vous vous une
intuition ouais vous dites pendant des
années les gens me confondaient avec les
vendeurs de rose à 1 € dans dans les
restaurants et vous dites c'est un signe
mon avenir est là et vous vous lancez
Cyril Hanouna dans la vente de rose à 1
€ dans les restaurants parisiens ex ça é
un carton tout de suite ça tout su
décollé en plus engageer des vendeurs
qui vous ressemblent donc comme les gens
se disent bah finalement c'est peut-être
cyil an j'ai contacté plein d'amis in
qui a rejoint la société très
vite quand les gens croient que c'est
vous ils ont moins tendance à dire non
et là vous avez une autre idée une idée
de de génie je crois qu'on peut le dire
sur chaque rose vous mettez en place une
garantie chopé ou remboursé c'est ça
c'est-à-dire que si l'homme qui achète
une rose pour l'offrir à la fille qui
est en face de lui n'arrive pas à
coucher avec elle vous remboursez la
rose je rembourse la
rose grande idée on a eu des menteurs
qui couchaient quand même qui essayent
de rendre la rose après mais Dieu soit N
on était dans tous les lits ouis là vous
rachetez les magasins au nom de la rose
de de Danis vous rachetez monceaufleur
ouais Interflora c'est Mar parce que
vous étiez le Napoléon de la télévision
et vous devenez Napoléon de la Rose
ouais et on regarde comment vos ex-amis
du PAF réagissent à votre descente aux
enfers et à votre subite reconversion
je ne peux que me souvenir de Cyril noun
parce qu'on a travaillé ensemble et
j'avais une incroyable tendresse pour
lui il s'est pas rendu compte qu'il qu'
avait des limites à l'exercice et qu'on
pouvait pas tout faire avec avec des
politiques moi le premier je savais
qu'il allait dans le mur mais mais je
l'ai encouragé parce que je savais que
derrière ça me laissait une autoroute
pour prendre sa place je suis
productrice et j'ai produit plein de
programmes suc s'est trompé pour les
Marseillais c'est la bonne question pour
un politique c'est pas possible j'ai pas
compris parce que moême même je venais
de la politique et et je sais que c'est
pas du tout le même exercice et puis
surtout on n pas du tout le même genre
de client on peut pas aller aussi loin
dans le sourire dans la blague c'est
offenser la France c'est offenser la
mission de service public et de
responsabilité publique d'un homme
politique malgré tout ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher ça reste un excellent
producteur un excellent businessman il
avait quand même réussi avant de Touche
pas à mes animaux à des H qui était
quand même la plus grosse arnaque de la
télévision et là aujourd'hui il cartonne
en vendant des roses c'est là-dessus il
a pas changé tant mieux pour lui puis
c'est ce qui pouvait arriver de mieux à
la à la télévision française et à moi
surtout mais je dois dire qu'à chaque
fois que je passe devant un fleuriste je
pense à lui et voilà
alors cy est-ce que vous êtes
nostalgique de l'époque Touche pas à mon
poste non plus du tout maintenant ah
ouais vraiment non je suis bien dans les
roses j'ai tourné la page quoi ah ouais
vraiment j'ai perdu plein d'amis bien
entendu qui était avec moi our de la
table ouais ont passé l'arme à gauche
ouais Gérard voilà je t'embrasse fort
Gérard
l et si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que
vous feriez la même chose ah oui vous
poseriez la question à Thierry solaire
exactement comme ah ou je suis plus
heureux maintenant ah ouais ouais
vraiment puis moi je j'avais pas envie
moi de j'avais envie d'arrêter au fond
de moi ah ouais Cyril le jour vous allez
mourir qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
écrive sur votre tombe qu'est-ce qu'on
est Siré au fond de cette boîte
c'est la
[Applaudissements]
meilleure est arrivé sur des h comme un
Pakistanais aujourd'hui vous êtes là
comme un Catari non ouai je me demande
si je vais pas racheter le plate
alors ruier Hanouna sur le même plateau
c'est pas une émission de télé mesdames
messieurs c'est
Yalta on va faire une photo pour
l'histoire on appellera ça les accords
de
[Applaudissements]
yal il a moins vieill que
moii jeun d'né en anné il est mieux
conservé alors en plus de la radio de la
télé du tennis vous chantez maintenant
la compile s'appelle touche pas à masic
le premier single s'appelle Bogda
Bogdanov featuring les frères Bogdanov
salut les
[Applaudissements]
extraterrestresoun merci d'avoir été
avec nous et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater debe abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce
bleu y